It's Thursday night and the Jaffa Flea Market is rocking.
Street vendors have set up tables laden with homemade crafts,...
...locally made clothes and unique accessories.
The Shuk is an attraction night or day for Israelis and tourists alike and especially in summer.
We read in the book that it's a good place to visit.
The most strong compliment that we can receive is when people buy our stuff...
...and when somebody is passing and just smiling by looking at one of the sculptures,...
...that makes my day.
This is one of the oldest markets in the world and whereas it used to be a place to find knickknacks...
...and secondhand furniture or clothing, today, it is also one of the trendiest spots in Israel.
Fashion designers, artists and gourmet chefs have all moved in...
...making it a destination for both bargain hunters and the stylish alike.